but on that key point of the
transmission the scientists then said
that later actually it turns out there's
not much difference between whether
you've had the jab or not for
transmission and at that point I
realized everything I've been saying was
completely wrong and completely unfair
and then it becomes a personal choice
again some will say well it should be a
personal choice anyway well yeah yeah
but if we had for example as one of the
Oxford AstraZeneca professors put it to
me if this had been the plague come back
with a 30 to 40 death rate including
kids how would people feel then if we
had a vaccine that was proven to be
largely successful and stopped
transmission and people were refusing to
have it and we were seeing not 3 000
people die a day but fifty thousand I
would say that people's views of that
argument might change quite you wouldn't
need to force anyone to take a vaccine
if it was the plate because right so
what my point being that the argument
would play slightly better if there were
much higher numbers of people dying
right which would come back to my sort
of thing that if the principles the
principle it doesn't really it shouldn't
really matter what the scale is but I
totally accept my rhetoric was over the
top